JP Morgan is growing in Florida and
Texas States like states that like
business Diamond says he says the
following about recession and uh some
people that were not part of these two
states were not happy play this clip
what are you worried about great to be
here by the way so thank you uh they're
very worried the most about if you go
it's Ukraine it's oil gas so the
leadership of the world and you know our
relationship with China I mean that that
is much more serious though the economic
vibrations we all have to deal with on a
day-to-day basis
I feel like it's so loud I don't know
what just happened with that clip if you
can because it's live until like Jamie
Damon yelling at that no he wasn't this
by the way all the audio rooms there is
a there's a 30-second clip of him saying
that you you have the longer one there's
a short of him saying that that he's
talking about it while you're looking
for that I'll just read the article here
uh he explains the JPMorgan Chase is
expanding in Florida opening branches we
can hear your typing opening brand
inches in a state that's seen an
increased influx of Wall Street firms
since the pandemic we love Florida
Florida we're grown in Florida left and
right Jamie Diamond says in an interview
in Miami it's part of a broader move
that's seen firms like Ken Griffin
Citadel move headquarters from Chicago
to Miami last year as well as Arc
investment Management's Kathy Wood
relocate to St Petersburg Florida
Florida and Texas are states that like
business they uh uh they want you to
come State they want you to come we now
have more employees in Texas than in New
York state it shouldn't have been that
way but Texas loves you being there okay
Texas loves you being there how long is
that this is 57 seconds it's pretty much
what he's saying it's the same thing I
just read play the clips or some
audience can see this poor countries and
it's roiling trade relations between
America China and the rest of the world
so this is a probably the most serious
geopolitical thing no it's playing the
other one it's just it's I don't know
what's going on your computer's out of
whack right now yeah it's not playing
don't worry what are your thoughts about
what Jamie's talking about Florida and
Texas Jamie is saying out loud what
everybody's been watching for the last
10 years that people are moving here and
now what Jamie is saying he is here's
what he's doing he's speaking in code
he's also speaking to the governor of
New York
you want me you want me to stay here you
need to start playing live so there's a
little you know what I mean Pat when you
say something to somebody and you leave
somebody out the person that's left out
gets the message but he's also stating
the obvious saying hey these states want
us to be here the climate's good that
things are good for business and it
shouldn't have to be that way but Texas
loves you being there with the emphasis
on the loves you being there they feel
welcome and he says and we're growing in
Florida yeah so it's where he's getting
growth so it's uh what I guess I guess I
mean I understand well and I'll show up
that's it so treat me well and I'll show
up I'll say one thing about Florida
being born and raised in Miami I
remember in the 80s and 90s where I was
like the weird cousin that lived in
Miami now it's not so weird now I'm like
it's cool to live in Florida but it's
it's it's kind of like Bittersweet to
that our little secret that our cat is
out the bag here in Florida a guy like
Pat should have never lived in Florida
he should have been in California
because that's where his family's from
but at some point you're gonna push
someone out who says like if I just do
this and this and this we've done this
all the time at some point a guy like
Pat is going to leave freaking
California I like a guy like Ken Griffin
is gonna leave New York he saw that he
was the number one hedge fund manager in
the world in the world by the way made
44 billion dollars what's the number
that he made somebody ridiculous
himself some ridiculous I think he left
Chicago by the way okay sorry but it I
get it yeah all these guys you know are
basically moving to Florida but what
what you what the leadership in Florida
that we've seen whether it's the Santa
is whether it's mayor Suarez down in
Miami
hedge funds are coming big techs coming
the crypto world has moved here it's
it's it's a very good climate to be in
literally and figuratively uh for
business and for lifestyle and I think
the cat's out the bag of what's going on
in South Florida and Florida overall so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]